ce message d'encouragement du maire de
dijon françois rebsamen lors de sa prise
de parole à l'université d'été du parti
socialiste à la rochelle il l'a martelé
le maire doit être au coeur du débat
avant les municipales en mars il a déjà
comme atout son expérience locale et
j'allais dire la preuve qui est fait
chaque jour de l'efficacité des
politiques que nous menons dans nos
communes de nos départements et dans nos
régions mais vu qu'il s'agit des
municipales j'ai d'abord parlé dans nos
villes dans nos communes dans nos
intercommunalités
aujourd'hui les français vous a très
bien que quand un élu socialiste avec
des élus de gauche dirige une ville
cette ville elle avance sur l'écologie
elle avance sur le social c'est à dire
que elle sait faire de l'écologie non
pas une punition mais un nouveau
possibles liens de pouvoir d'achat
prenons l'exemple du logement si vous
voulez quand nous faisons des kilomètres
et des kilomètres de réseaux de chaleur
c'est pour permettre aux gens les plus
modestes dans les quartiers et bien tout
simplement d'avoir un mois de moins de
charges de chauffage c'est comme ça
qu'on va faire avancer l'écologie et la
social écologie
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a fait comprendre